à l'occasion des 30 ans de hip-hop à
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines le scarabée à
La Verrière organise un tremplin de
musique
urbaine cette groupe de l'agglomération
seront sur scène le samedi 12 avril et
nous en parlons ce soir avec Miss Kelly
bonsoir bonsoir vous allez animer cette
soirée et vous êtes venu accompagner de
masse bonsoir vous allez être l'un des
membres du jury alors déjà pour
commencer Miss Kaeli pour vous présenter
pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas
alors vous êtes une figure montante
hip-hop à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
dernière actu en date un album qui va
prochainement sortir on s'appelle
bienvenue en zone franche et donc vous
allez vous animer aussi régulièrement
des scènes slam des open mind donc
derrière le dernier en date c'était le
hip-hoptour session à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux car une nuit a pas
mal de monde alors samedi 12 avril au
scarabée c'est un tremplin comment ça va
se passer
comment ça va se passer en fait il y a
6 villes de la communauté
d'agglomération qui propose chacune
enfin les services jeunesse plus
précisément qui proposent chacun un
groupe de leur ville pour la verrière
d'ailleurs il y en a deux et voilà les
jeunes seront
évalués on va dire ils vont faire ils
vont passer chacun leur tour sur la
scène et puis ils auront en phase 2 un
jury avec des critères qui qui choisira
un groupe un groupe qui fera la première
partie de Sultan le 25 avril parce que
c'est un concours tout à fait un gagnant
et à la clé évidemment voilà la première
partie de Sultan et ce sera le 25 avril
au scarabée en tête cité les sept
groupes donc en compétition parce que ça
reste une compétition alors Astro boys
ils sont dans des longs courts on a
osgang de Guyancourt ramdam et le
constat la verrière opacity à Manille
kurta de Montigny-le-Bretonneux et Diaz
de Trappes alors masse vous donc vous
allez être l'un des membres du jury
pareil peut-être pour vous présenter
vous allez me dire si j'ai juste donc
vous avez fait vos débuts en 94 dans le
rap à votre actif de nombreuses
collaborations vont citer quelques-unes
phares comme NTM et Diam's par exemple
donc entre autres vous avez intégré le
label bio SS également créer votre
propre label et puis parmi vos multiples
activités en parallèle vous menez des
ateliers d'écriture avec les jeunes
justement du territoire et c'est ça qui
m'intéresse justement vous les côtoyer
régulièrement qu'est-ce qui selon vous
est important
qu'est-ce qui sur quoi vous les allez
les évaluer samedi 2 avril je pense que
ce qui est important c'est la
personnalité déjà donc au travers de sa
musique bah c'est ce qu'il faut laisser
transparaître être soi-même je pense que
c'est le plus important parce que quand
on rentre justement dans les codes
des codes qui peut par la suite devenir
des clichés on est un peu perdu là
dedans donc je pense que c'est voilà le
plus important c'est vraiment de rester
soi-même et c'est de véhiculer
son vécu ou sa façon de penser ou sa
manière de voir les choses mais voilà je
pense que la première des choses c'est
être soi-même essayer de leur donner des
codes enfin par la suite parce que
normalement après le tremplin c'est
essayer de justement de travailler un
peu toute cette mise en scène pour
pouvoir se produire sur scène vous allez
leur donner des conseils aussi voilà bon
enfin après voilà ça ça reste quoi qu'il
arrive à mon niveau mais bon je pense
avoir accumulé quand même pas mal de sel
et dans différentes
postures je dirais c'était pas forcément
le même public les mêmes gens ou le nom
voilà donc voilà j'essaierai de leur
donner des des petites choses que j'ai
que j'aurais pu apprendre aux parents
un extrait de trois
dès qu'on a que des clips vidéos de
trois des groupes qui se produiront donc
le 12 avril
de m'éloigner tout ça rien que pour toi
j'ai jamais touché à l'alcool ni au
crack même si parfois je craque les
nerfs lâche mais bon j'essaye de
m'éloigner tout ça j'essaie de
m'éloigner des fous des racistes des
lâches je veux pas quitter ce monde sans
avoir rempli ma tâche entière ma famille
avoir un taf et surtout ta voix toi
j'aime pas être le centre de l'intention
comme il faut que je préfère l'ombre
comment faire dans son petit bal inverse
de mes principes on est que des hommes
je le redis on se prend ton air au teint
parce que ton numéro de compte est mieux
mis tu mérites juste continuer
convulsion ignoble on prie Macédoine
pour qu'il ait besoin de frites les
rêves les rêves sont loin quand je
marque un temps d'arrêt j'envoie ça leur
je m'active je crois pas en la poisse
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent dire par
oublier de passer sachant que celui qui
m'a formé je sais pas si tout est tracé
les Sims répètent le soir je médite des
fois même si on admet pas de défaite mon
Didier
alors ce tremplin donc s'adresse à des
jeunes de 16 à 25 ans qu'est-ce qu'il
faut Miss kaïly selon vous comme
maptitude aujourd'hui pour faire sa
place dans le monde du hip-hop
ça dépend les intentions de chacun après
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire faire sa
place en fait pour avoir une certaine
raison en tout cas au vu de du public et
ben il faut je vais rejoindre ce que
disait masse faut être super cohérent
avec qui on est parce que ça permet de
grandir avec sa plume et grandir avec sa
musique après pour que ça résonne pour
que ça résonne aujourd'hui
il y a aussi un travail sur la vidéo je
trouve à faire un gros travail sur la
vidéo être assez présent sur les réseaux
sociaux quelque part parce que voilà
c'est aussi un travail de com à fond
peut-être plus qu'il n'y avait par
exemple pour vous en 94 c'était
différent alors justement comment s'est
passé l'évolution comment vous notez
vous cette évolution du rap aujourd'hui
là en fait les 30 ans de hip-hop sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines quelle est la
différence par rapport à 30 ans
après je pense que c'est toute la
musique qui a évolué donc avant c'était
il y avait une espèce de
recherche dans le sens où comme c'était
pas accessible il fallait creuser donc
on avait tous un peu dans dans l'idée de
d'avoir la de trouver la petite pépite
mais maintenant en fait je veux pas
parler de façon
il y a beaucoup de choses donc justement
pour faire sa place dans tout ça c'est
d'autant plus compliqué bien bien
même si on a on a cet élément on
sait ce qu'on veut on sait ce qu'on peut
y mettre ou voilà quand on est sur scène
on fait le travail mais c'est vrai que
pour véhiculer le message à l'heure
actuelle plus importante et c'est
d'autant plus compliqué alors comment se
différencie qu'est-ce qu'il fait la
différence avec une question bonne
question
sur le côté commercial après ça
satisfait un public voilà il y a un fou
pour tous les goûts et puis il y en a
d'autres qui cultivent justement une
différence et quel conseil on pourrait
donner à ces jeunes qui voudraient être
dans la différence
est-ce qu'elle par exemple vous votre
différence ça serait quoi comment vous
pouvez vous définir justement
effectivement dans le le hip-hop est pas
très féminin
c'est une question que j'ai depuis 10
ans enfin voilà donc ça déjà ça cultive
votre différence mais au-delà de ça
au-delà de ça il vous donnera ces jeunes
ou leur instinct leur dit d'aller voilà
et de faire les choses voilà très
instinctivement et très eux-mêmes voilà
je rejoins encore masse
après on peut vite se perdre à essayer
d'être différent
c'est quoi différent [__] on est enfin
on est pour moi on est tous différents
ce qu'on est tous des êtres humains à
part entière on est tous des gosses de
l'univers et voilà faire les choses
faire les choses comme on en a envie
voilà se lever le matin on se regardant
dans la glace en étant content de ce
qu'on fait et on se sentant bien à
l'aise dans ses chaussures quoi voilà
moi c'est mon point de vue après il y a
des gens qui ont un charisme et qui ont
quelque chose qui fait qu'on va plus les
remarquer que d'autres bah on est qui on
est quoi voilà un conseil
faites ce que vous avez à faire et comme
vous avez envie de le faire faire en
sorte de pas être récupéré et emmener
dans des dans des espaces où on n'a pas
forcément envie d'aller
après il y en a qui ont une démarche
purement commerciale ils sont mis au rap
parce qu'ils ont vu qu'il y avait de
l'argent à se faire et que c'était il
comment dire ils ont une approche qui
est c'est un business quoi alors il y a
aussi une dernière question que
j'aimerais vous poser il y a une espèce
de paradoxe dans le rap
souvent vous prenez des valeurs des
valeurs de partage et vous vous
rejoignez tous les deux là-dessus sur
chacun de vos sites internet vous parlez
de partage on parle aussi d'ouverture
d'esprit on parle d'échange et pourtant
au regard du grand public parfois le rap
peut être considéré un peu comme négatif
pourquoi ce paradoxe selon vous nous on
a un mouvement qui vient de la rue et ça
inquiète beaucoup parce que on est très
brut très franc si on propose un vrai
spectacle et qu'on amène quelque chose
de vraiment intéressant je peux vous
dire que cette jeunesse
elle va être là elle va être
opérationnelle et elle va soutenir je
pense que si le fait de mettre le rap
dans de mettre le rap c'est à dire que
prendre tous les éléments négatifs parce
que généralement c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on va mettre en avant et c'est ce
qu'on va voir et du coup ça ça et on met
moins en évidence ce qui se passe à côté
pourtant il y a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de choses et donc je pense que
médiatiquement il est en portant parce
que moi le la plupart des scènes que je
fais les personnes viennent me voir donc
j'ai été dans des endroits complètement
différents et j'aime pas trop le rap
mais ce que vous faites j'aime ce que
vous faites mais ça reste du rap c'est à
dire que voilà donc c'est un peu
paradoxal donc le paradoxe aussi est
dans dans les esprits et dans toutes ces
choses là donc quelque part
voilà et vous dire que le rap c'est
c'est large à plusieurs styles et il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de richesses et donc
si vous ouvrez les portes
et vous en fait vous allez commencer à
les découvrir petit à petit et après ça
en fait moi je pense qu'il faut un
équilibre c'est à dire comme il y a le
rap violent il y a pas que le rap
violent donc comme malheureusement
visuellement enfin médiatiquement ou
toutes ces choses là on en place un là
et l'autre là donc forcément on voit que
celui là donc si vous commencez à quand
je dis vous d'ordre général enfin
médiatiquement je pense que c'est c'est
super important on a vraiment faut
valoriser les choses faut valoriser les
choses et bien tout simplement c'est
d'être présent le samedi 12 avril c'est
à 20h30 au scarabée on aura justement
une palette de différents styles c'est
un tarif unique à un euro 50 merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'être venu
merci
père et fille à la ville comme à la
Seine il donne vie au texte d'Angela de
maté et incarne de vision du monde de
radicalement différente dans l'Italie
des années de plomb ils seront notamment
le 29 avril au prisme à Élancourt avec
j'avais un beau ballon rouge elle c'est
romane et lui c'est notre invité voici
Richard Bohringer dans le kiosque
oui c'est l'histoire d'un prolétère
catholique de l'Italie pendant les
années de plomb et il s'est fonce pour
envoyer de sa fille à l'université sa
fille tombera amoureuse d'un théoricien
révolutionnaire et
elle le suivra il partiront tous les
deux sur les routes des Brigades Rouges
pendant que le père
ses vertus
à essayer de la convaincre il sent le
danger il sent les choses
à la convaincre de quitter tout ça quoi
c'est très amusant de jouer à catholique
prolétaire si tu es très très amusant
quoi
fin de compte c'est pas loin de la
vérité donc
c'est tellement bien de jouer avec sa
fille
c'est tellement bien que je le
recommande à tout le monde d'ailleurs
ça
se trouve
du café ou pas merci
et moi je me demandais
qu'est-ce que vous avez comme intention
avec Renato
comment ça non je veux dire si vous avez
dans l'idée de vous marier
c'est une pièce six personnes c'est joli
pièce assez rayonnante sur la ville la
mort et sur le couple du d'un père et de
sa fille sa fille qui qui se barre dans
des
qui s'échappe du
cocon qui s'échappe de
du bien-pensant qui s'échappe de tout ça
voilà c'est tout c'est aussi simple
aujourd'hui il y a des mouvements qui se
préparent il y a des trucs
c'est pas forcément très gai mais il y a
des révoltes il y a des jusqu'en
boutistices il y a il y a tout ça
il y a des millions de gens qui pensent
des millions de jeunes gens qui pensent
aux dérives des hommes en place de la
politique aux mensonges politiciens
au mensonges républicain c'est une vaste
c'est une valse tout ça
une maison une bagnole les vacances à la
mer et après
ça me suffit pas moi qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire mais ça veut dire que toi et
moi on n'est pas pareil moi je serai pas
fichu de vivre seulement pour ça quand
on fait de la scène libre c'est sûr
qu'après il faut retrouver les places le
théâtre c'est il y a des places il y a
des endroits il y a des temps qui sont
régis par la pièce et non par vous-même
c'est sûr donc la scène la des vertus la
des vertus c'est rarement rencontré au
cinéma
la même densité
que sur la route sur scène
c'est à la fois
un rayonnement une lumière comme ça tout
à fait particulière mais en même temps
quand magazine les kilomètres les hôtels
les machins ainsi de suite en même temps
il y a tu te sépare un peu
c'est peut-être ça la vraie volonté du
mec sur la route c'est de se séparer
c'est une espèce d'exil informel comme
ça vous passez vraiment que cette
histoire de la Révolution c'est pas une
durée toute la vie
c'est vrai que c'est peut-être un peu
ignare j'ai récupéré
mais j'ai bien une chose Marguerite
on sait ce qu'il y a
petit à petit tu te rends compte que toi
aussi tu la veux ta maison tes vacances
et être avec les tiens
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
là je vais me faire un bon film cet été
c'est une histoire entre un père sa
fille je suis très content de le faire
très très content de le faire
j'aime beaucoup avec Maki je fais des
courts-métrages je retrouve les sources
quoi les sources les sources
les hommes on peut guère les changer
le rappeler qu'il existe l'humilité la
dignité le respect on peut pas les
obliger à être dessin Marguerita voilà
ce que je pense moi
il y a rien à faire quoi
c'est normal que tu penses comme ça
c'est toute une tradition qui te fait
penser comme ça je gagne ma vie
je gagne ma vie
je suis avec ma fille avec ses enfants
je joue tous les soirs dans une ville
différente quelques jours
on se fait des attaches très vite
on a des souvenirs après
les souvenirs sonores d'une ville qu'on
connaissait pas il y a pas que jouer
quand je suis sur la route avec Romane
il y a vivre avec elle
elle est dans la chambre d'à côté à
l'hôtel de temps en temps le temps pour
me demander un truc quoi c'est la
renaissance de plein de choses enfouis
et c'est bien de le vivre avec ma fille
quoi c'est peut-être pas un des derniers
trucs comme ça ensemble qu'on vit quoi
la vie donc je le prends avec un appétit
alors qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire selon
toi ton fils à la poubelle pourquoi pas
et ben moi je sais pas
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'on est que
de passage sur cette terre
voilà
et après j'avais un beau ballon rouge
voici celle qui avait un joli cerceau
jaune et oui je sais tout Aurélia
mon coup de cœur cette semaine c'est
viva la liberté infinitalien avec Tony
servilleau c'est un film absolument
superbe bourré de fantaisie mais qui dit
aussi plein de choses sur la vie sur la
politique sur le passé sur le futur
vraiment venez le voir en VO je précise
ça fait trois semaines que je le
programme parce que j'essaye de soutenir
ce film et vous les téléconcerez